it's clear in my book that didn't think
the Democratic leaders were the best
suited to reach out to the very voters
Democrats lost in the last four years
that I do believe there was stronger
Democratic candidates out there but that
doesn't really matter at this point it's
going to be Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama and I would emphasize again that
even when John Edwards was in that race
I felt the same way about the top three
so it's not simply because it's in fact
not at all because Hillary is a woman in
barracks an african-american in fact
Hillary Clinton laxed what has been
quite successful for female candidates
and appealing to men as well as women
which is she wasn't a former prosecutor
that's been a wonderful way for female
governors for example to show their
toughness their grit to basically deal
with the stereotypes that they have to
deal with his women which is that
they're not tough enough or willing to
you know make the hard choices and as I
like to remind people men also deal with
their stereotypes that they're not
sensitive that they don't care look at
Joe Biden Joe but what Joe Biden said
that our Barack Obama was quote-unquote
articulate certain and cleaning
articulate certainly was like a bit
strange but what people missed was Tiger
Woods in describing Barack Obama in one
sentence about two weeks ago used the
words articulate right away what Biden
did was stupid for a politician came in
in an opportune time but he was held to
that dinner because he's a white guy and
that's fine because women have to
disprove stereotypes white guys have
disappear types and certainly Barack
Obama's in African America has had to
disprove stereotypes in this race so
what matters now is if it's Barack Obama
or Hillary Rodham Clinton as the nominee
what can these candidates do to reach
out to these men I talked about that in
the last chapter of my book and so are
the policies and stances and the way in
which these candidates should try to
define themselves to the public and
certainly the attributes of themselves
they should emphasize but they should
also consider the vice presidential
selection very very carefully now vice
presidents don't make a huge difference
but they are important they're important
because one you don't want to do any
arm but to you want to pick a candidate
possibly compensates for your weaknesses
and three you want to pick a candidate
who possibly can help you in a state
that whole idea about that can be
present from day one is nice but they're
not worried too much about that though
they don't want someone who appears on
presidential so they should very
seriously consider that both of them
have weaknesses on national security and
I'm says the including Hillary Rodham
Clinton and both of them have weaknesses
on experience and that they should
possibly look for a candidate that maybe
does fit the Republican archetype of
candidates they have put forward in the
last 25 years that doesn't mean demic
that doesn't mean Republican light that
doesn't mean moderation with our
principles it doesn't mean really the
middle row that so many of the left are
infuriated about not at all it simply
just it simply means a president a vice
presidential candidate that to a
significant extent comes from the
America that is warming to the
Democratic Party but not ready to marry
them there are there's certainly our
candidates out there that fit that bill
I'll just name some and I really want to
emphasize I'm I could miss several and
that this is purely from a head but of
course candidates like Wesley Clark uh
you know the general the former general
from Arkansas helps would help a good
deal I think he learned lessons in
campaigning in 2004 and he certainly
would compensate for Hillary Rodham
Clinton's national security weaknesses
and Barak's though that Hillary and him
both come from this the same state might
pose a small dilemma though he is
southern and Democrats should remember
that they have not won a presidential
race since nineteen sixty with out a
southern or at the top or the second
slot of the ticket so that's an
important fact to consider too there are
tenants like Brian's right to the
governor of Montana i'm not sure if
you'd want it there's the governor of
ohio he says to me he doesn't want it
Strickland he says he told me personally
twice that he's not interested that he's
he's older and that he's
happy in Ohio but he certainly
compensates for moral values weaknesses
that have haunted the Democratic Party
for a long time and when I see more
values i mean the inference that it has
a conservatives and moderates out there
and there's certainly Jim Webb out of
Virginia that I think is a strong
candidate for the vice presidential slot
and there are many others that I could
name those are just three with no
particular preference though who
certainly help compensate for Democratic
historical weaknesses I would also add
Mark Warner to that mix also from a
junior former governor who's shown a
consistent ability to really close gaps
on such issues as guns that have haunted
the Democratic Party for some decades